but it isn't open to us because while
joe biden is
effectively opening our southern border
he is threatening
to close the border with florida
mexico totally fine no wall no border
florida they're probably going to build
a big beautiful wall around florida by
the time joe biden is done jinsaki
was asked about this because it is being
seriously floated now
that the united states at the federal
level could halt
travel to and from florida the miami
herald reported yesterday that the biden
administration is considering travel
restrictions on states like florida
to help stop the spread of the
coronavirus can you rule that out or is
that off
as they say on the table well i've seen
those reports
we are always considering what steps are
necessary to keep the american people
safe but we are not currently
in the process of no decisions have been
made around additional
public health measures that would delay
or would change i should say
domestic travel uh considerations
joe biden should have used zip recruiter
unfortunately for him he did not and
this woman was not very persuasive
she doesn't want to come out right in
front and say yeah we're going to cut
off travel from florida we're going to
prevent federal employees from
however they're going to do it but she
doesn't say no it's a ridiculous it's an
absolutely preposterous idea florida has
done so
much better on coronavirus than new york
than california than
many other places in chicago many other
places in the country
but all those cities and states are run
by
liberals so that's totally fine totally
open ron desantis the republican
is running florida florida's done a
great job so now we've got to talk about
the cases skyrocketing and whatever
we've got to cut it off desantis came
out obviously and
pushed back against this pretty hard
it's a it's a reordering of the country
which way are we going to go are we
going to
knock down our national borders and
build up borders within ourselves
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you